مناورات الصين ومحاكاه حصار تايوان انتهت
يوم امس لكن اذا ارادت الصين غزوه تايوان
فما سيناريوهات المحتمله يرى محللون
عسكريون ان موقع تايوان الجغرافي كجزيره
مفصوله عن البر الرئيس للصين نقطه قوه
وضعف
في حال حدوث غزو لتايوان يمكن للصين حصار
الجزيره التي تعتمد على اعاده الامداد
والتسلح عبر الجو والبحر واغلاق هذه الطرق
يعتبر خنقا للجزيره ايضا الحصار سيتسبب في
انهاك تايوان اقتصاديا وعسكريا مع بقاء
القوات المسلحه التايوانيه على اهبه
الاستعداد فتره طويله التحليلات تشير الى
ان الصين ستبدا في اي هجوم على تايوان
بالهجوم على الجزر التابعه لها والاقرب
جغرافيا الى البر الصيني مثل جزر ماتسو
وكيمن احتلال بعض او كل هذه الجزر سيكون
بمثابه اعراض قوه للصين واختبارا لمدى
الرغبه الغربيه في مسانده تايوان ودعمها
من الحلول التي قد تلجا اليها الصين
شنهجمات جويه محدوده لاستهداف الدفاعات
الساحليه ومواقع الرادار والمطارات تمهيدا
لهجوم اكبر بعد كسر دفاعات التايوانيه اما
وضع الغزو البري الشامل فسيتم عبر الانزال
البرمائي في نقاط استراتيجيه بعد عبور
مضيق تايوان بسرعه وتحت غطاء من القصف
بالصواريخ والطائرات المقاتله وفضلا عن
الحرب التقليديه من المرجح ان يتم استخدام
الحرب الالكترونيه على نطاق واسع لتعطيل
اتصالات تايوان وبث الذعر بين عامه الناس
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات